chris everyone else on my show has had
the chance to interview you except me
and now it's finally my turn and i'm
very excited let's do it
all right light year there's going to be
a ton of toys coming out from this movie
i want to know as a kid what was your
favorite growing up
uh a toy story toy or just any toy any
well could be if that was your toy maybe
that was your jam any toy i mean i i was
really big into uh thundercats i was
really big into ninja turtles um g-man
uh yeah but but probably donatello was
probably the one that i was you know
most proud of
i love that now were you obsessed with
the cat as much as we all were socks and
really
what does dodger think of this are you
going to get a cat now that's right no
of course i was obsessed with socks who
isn't i mean he steals the entire movie
um i i almost
i i tell myself in my brain they made
him those colorings to model after
dodger i when i first saw socks i said
you know aside from the fact that he's a
cat right i see his dodger
okay fair enough that's fair and listen
i just want to say if you ever need a
babysitter for dodger
you can ship dodger up here to canada
and i've got you covered that's becoming
a long line i'll tell you okay um what
made you want to do this film so much i
mean it's such an incredible franchise
and and has such a great story but for
you what was it
well i mean those things you just said
but but for me it's you know i just
wanted to work with pixar i i've yeah i
love pixar ever since the first toy
story film and i'm a huge animation fan
in general
but my team called to tell me that pixar
wanted to chat
everybody was on the call you know
you're
yeah it's in your manager and if you get
a call with everybody on the call it's
either uh it's either really good news
or really bad news um and and they all
wanted to be on the call because they
knew
how much it would matter to me to hear
that pixar was interested so i kind of
said look no matter what this is
i'm doing it
oh my gosh amazing can i do one thing
with you can i do
infinity
and beyond
boom
oh i love it now my day is made all
right next up you're going to be
fighting with ryan gosling who is our
you know our canadian treasure i just
want to know was the mustache line in
the trailer an ad-lib or was that
scripted and did you hurt him at all do
we need to know ryan is an unbelievable
ad-libber it's really funny that scene
specifically um they did they just
released the clip where i kind of spray
him with mace yeah
and every time he kind of has his eyes
closed sprayed with that mace he would
just kind of every take just just riff
on on why he thought
that i was lloyd
and it was tough to not break because
he's so funny but uh
yeah i just posted something recently
that was the first day of filming with
him and i accidentally hit him right in
the face i was holding the gun as i
slammed him into the wall and you know
you had the gun in the hand and you slam
into the wall and the gun just boom
right off of his front lip
he took it like a champ though i mean he
handled it we went right back into
another take but
not the best way to start the working
process no that's not how you want to
start it off for sure
this uh back to to the movie um there's
such a great message of inclusion
even seeing a senior citizen really rip
it you know and be so powerful um what
are you hoping families will get out of
this
i'm not sure what the question is get
what will families get out of the
message of inclusion yeah well just what
are you hoping to walk away with be
having their kids see all of this so
beautifully displayed sure well i mean
the the message you know in terms of
what pixar does
so well is weave multiple themes into
their stories you know whether it's
messages of inclusion where it's you
know long overdue uh messages of
understanding that family is
what you make it that it doesn't have to
be
just circumstantial it almost comes from
within
but the message i like the most is this
idea that
your mistakes
don't define you
and and living in them can actually
stunt
your growth that that mistakes are
actually an opportunity to evolve
definitely well thank you so much chris
this was great i'm glad i waited this
long i mean it was worth the wait oh
that makes me
you